[Musique]
il y avait un patient la aux soins
cardiaques qui a récupéré le poteau de
traitement sur lui heureusement par une
volonté divine
il a survécu mais non il est en bonne
santé
pour notre part nous on a pu
reconstruire et réhabiliter cette
chambre comme on a réhabilité toute
l'unité de soins tertiaires
[Musique]
grâce à des à des donateurs privés à des
groupes de donateurs nous avons pu
reprendre les la reconstruction de
l'hôpital nous avons préfet fini à
environ 80% de la reconstruction
[Musique]
donc ça c'est notre espace d urgence
bonjour bonjour aujourd'hui ta problème
actuellement n'est pas n'est plus un
problème de structure pour le moment de
ce que nous faisons face à une crise
économique
le départ des soignants de départ
affirmées et le manque de médicaments et
aussi éventuellement le manque de
logistique d'électricité de mazout de
flux de désert pour faire fonctionner
l'hôpital
problème c'est qu'on se sent en fait
nous incapables de vendre nos malades
actuellement
quand je reçois un coup de fil et que
j'arrive pas à trouver une solution à
montmollin c'est vraiment très difficile
psychologiquement
[Musique]
et tellement mon salaire vaut 60 à 65
dollars par mois alors que avant la
crise ils étaient entre 800 et 900 donc
on fait ce qu'il faut mais à la fin on a
juste de quoi survivre à pain dans un
pays qui a handicapé par la corruption
le manque de moyens le manque de de
rentrer je ne peux pas avoir ça ici je
ne peux pas avoir de stabilité adéquat
donc oui honnêtement je pense je pense
partir maintenant revenir ça c'est une
autre question j'espère bien dans le
futur que la situation serait beaucoup
mieux parce que finalement c'est c'est
le pénis et
[Musique]